talk in a different language don't know
who politicians that's why nobody's
voting for them anymore but I call it
all this weekís political BS what
politicians are speaking about a lot in
this election our hope and opportunity
for those who are really struggling for
the many not the few building a Britain
that's better for everyone
we've heard the slogans I don't work or
for me
disability I've got depression panic
attacks
osteo arthritis in my knees and spine so
you're both on benefit yeah
Donna's story lives in a council house
in Lincoln with her family is me Jasmine
my knees and above the pole just come
from school Jasmine yet school yeah if
you want to climb up the ladder money
and class matter more than ever
according to the social mobility
Commission I just managed I mean I get
paid on every fortnight on a Friday and
what I get it just manages to pay the
bills
pay for the food mmm at the end of it
nothing's left get to the shop milk yeah
no don't need bread bleach no cigarette
papers social mobility is getting harder
and the main parties are trying to
capture aspirational voters positionally
neighbors always been the party here for
people to cut work and that's a problem
for labour some say it needs to smash
the notion its focus has shifted too far
towards the disadvantaged
I've got errotica right is a guy in the
shoulder elbow and and boat me knees and
ankles and we shouldn't have been going
in we back I've also got bad circulation
and cuz I'm honorary diabetes
I get fatigued a lot this doc you can't
lift that one it's too heavy now you let
yourself move it I know people do think
we're scroungers cuz we're on many
things
who's that again how long have you been
on benefits then well about trying to
work out 14 years by god there's so many
people that are taking benefits for
granted a few miles away it's tea break
time at a Lincoln Factory far too many
people are taking far too much money out
the pockets of the likes of us guys
these workers are making machinery to
resurface floors they are key targets in
the sights of the Tory party which
believes that just about managing
working-class voters will decide this
election I'm in situation I'm then on
working in my household so we are barely
getting by la we cover our bills and we
have a few pens to work together then
the multiplying me it's it's not living
this is you getting by darling you mean
conservatives traditionally known as
being for their middle to high class
people like you mean would you call
yourself working-class allowed think so
yeah and so was it unthinkable almost in
the past that you would have even
considered voting Tory definitely yeah
yeah and are you alone in your family
about thinking that you might vote Tory
or is it something which is going on
amongst I'm oh yeah yeah yeah my mum my
parents my partner remember oh I'm
ffensive LY we're all inside I say we're
all traditional labor voters like other
parties are sound appealing line you
mean sir that's a big development isn't
it yes
ug this country's only got one party and
that's Conservative Party
you couldn't vote for labour you know it
bankrupt the countries but even bad
enough economic state as it is without
without an idiot idiot from Labour
labor has been trying to woo the
undecideds
I just want to say this is I'm really
pleased to be a mover
it's a bellwether seat held by the
Tories the kind of place labor should be
taking if they're to win the election
Dena Dimmick believes it's labour who
will best help those on not much money
better themselves
she was once on benefits but hopes to
train as a paramedic I've always voted
labour always sorry I've never never
swayed into voting any other and you're
not going to save this time no mo
stuffing on no Dena's ten-year-old
daughter Mugen wants to become a pilot
she didn't get a Grammar School place
only four percent of doctors and 6% of
barristers are from working class
backgrounds labour opposes the expansion
of selective education one of the
policies of two's amazed that she said
she wants to support having more grammar
schools is that a policy that would
entice you to vote for tourism a yes I
do
I do like that however I don't think it
benefit a lot of other people it's not
fair well by all them but other people
are a bit more less educated so to speak
that's not enough one reason it's not to
sway me over to conservatives it's
really not with three children money is
tight we don't remember wow we don't
know anything that is very it literally
is bills and food and and things like
that to keep her head above water really
as they were only just managing to do
that Dena's partner Jamie is an
ex-soldier who works up to sixty hours a
week in security in March unemployment
in the UK fell to a 42-year low but at
the same time real wages have also
fallen so people have less money in
their pockets I'm on a wage that someone
10-15 years ago would have been on and I
would look to his parents and seen him
running a household perfectly fine
within mourn enough disposable income on
the same ways I'm on now because the
cost of everything's gone up but the
wage has not moved that I'm in the same
position he would have been in but I'm a
lot worse off and I can't stand how that
works but within their budget they pay
for private health care if you describe
yourself as almost like just about
managing family yeah that's really quite
something today to take out the money
for private health is it cost me like I
say I'm left with absolutely nothing
nothing out of my income at all and it
cost me 117 pound which is quite a lot
of money but I mean our sucks a month
yeah I sacrificed quite a lot to get
that but you just can't put a price on
done on health care especially not when
it comes to the children
that's what were you made that will pay
privately same thing NHS will and
everything will be privatized right the
railways like the bus services you know
and we'll all be paying choices in you
mean make actual atoms all the time just
here just to live life the Austin's
trying to get on the housing ladder
that's almost impossible for them now
it's that thing that's important to you
is you you've got two children twenty
five and eight eighty yes it is because
they are our future I'm not a a Tory
through and through however had it not
been for mrs. Thatcher in those days we
wouldn't own our own houses if you're
born working-class do you think you'll
stay working-class yeah what did you
want to be when you left school yeah
train driver postman
for what just get your package up
without special so you spent 18 years
after leaving school without being able
to find a job and when you got a job
what job did you get a car park
attendant did you did you enjoy that job
oh look dick ugly mr. day's work was
like once I got a job
no mr. day's hardly a day's work it's
like getting into a mindset if you got a
job you're more likely to work harder at
the ER where after a period have been
unemployed he seemed to get go towards
that there's no hope you give up yeah
well I
I will steamy ganya the teller on the
electric other about the gas because you
don't need it here what are your hopes
for the future for yourself I haven't
gotten it
I probably a beer living in the council
house for some fee would you like to own
a house your own no why yes tradition
previously I've looked in council houses
all me life and I don't believe we
should be right to buy but what about
people who want to better themselves
they want to maybe live in a house
that's bigger than this or Oh bigger
then in a in a what you might call a
Pasha area oh yeah does that not appeal
to you no I'm up here
can you imagine ever having a home of
your own that is your home yeah yeah I
can eventually but I'm not one on one of
these kind of people that will go out
and get it I just suddenly the first
year or so since I've left the army so
I've kind of been sorting myself out and
then I'll go and use my skills to get
better job better myself and then
eventually be able to afford Manhart if
you happy and you know it son you really
want to share with if you're happy and
you know it clap your hands
yeah
you